let me show you the subconscious power
of this device what if I were to hold my
phone while I'm giving this presentation
I'm not checking it it's not buzzing
it's not beeping I'm simply holding it
do you feel like you're the most
important thing to me right now no you
do not and this is an artificial
environment now think about how often
this phone is out while we're talking to
other people hey boss can I talk to you
sure what's on your mind as opposed to
sure what's on your mind we go out for
dinner or lunch with our family and our
friends
we have meetings and we put the phone on
the table which sends a subconscious
message to everybody else in the room
that this is not that important to me
you're not that important to me and by
the way putting your phone upside down
is not more
polite this is this is my favorite one
where the phone rings in the middle of a
dinner in the middle of a lunch in the
middle of a meeting and somebody
goes I'm not going to answer it oh my
God just so magnanimous